An Empire not of Conquerors
whose campaign across the universe would forever prove
even the darkest of hearts can come to no peace.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
This will be my Full Marvel
What if Season 2 Episode 7 video
There were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs and references
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We only have a couple episodes left this season,
but we will be getting
What if season 3 at least by 2025
I don't think it's coming next year,
but we'll see Careful for Spoilers
If you haven't seen the episode yet,
we'll start at the beginning
Work our way through shop by shot
talking about Easter eggs, wtf moments and everything
that's going to lead up to the last
two episodes are basically saying
that they're going to be like a two part finale
Almost starting with the episode titled
What If Hela Found the Ten Rings
is basically a speed run version
of the plot of the first Thor movie,
but with Hela cross with some of the plot
of the Shanghai She movie and Avengers
Infinity War with that tag scene at the end
it's the shortest episode of the season
is about the same length though is a normal 30 minute
episode of television on broadcast TV, like on cable,
which usually winds up being closer
to about 23, 24 minutes without any commercials.
as you could probably tell, Cate
Blanchett came back to play Hela again.
I believe she's also a big part of the Marvel
1602 episode, maybe even the finale.
Idris Elba also came back to play Heimdall again,
but pretty much everybody else in
the episode was played by a brand new actor
like Wenwu Odin.
We're both played by brand new people.
they use the standard speed run,
super quick version of the Marvel Studios
intro in the Marvel Studios fanfare.
like, there's no special theme music.
At the beginning of this episode,
the Watcher narrates how history changed
in this universe
after Hela Odin finished conquering the nine realms.
As you saw during the backstory
in Thor Ragnarok, Odin decides to stop.
Instead of continuing to conquer the entire universe.
Like originally, that was the plan.
Odin was trying to conquer the entire universe.
Hela rebels against him because she wants to continue
their fight, just as she did in the MCU movies.
But instead of imprisoning her in hell, she'll Marvel's
version of Asgard's underworld in the MCU
is just an alternate dimension.
He banishes her to earth
after stripping her of her powers
in a scene
that's basically copy pasted from the first Thor movie.
it plays out pretty much the same way
it did with Thor in that movie.
they start on the mural that sits on the roof
of the throne room that Odin later had painted over,
hiding their true bloody history of Asgard.
All these people, as it pans across their soldiers
from the different armies that are fighting them,
I believe that these soldiers are meant to be from Bay
Anaheim, which is where Frigga comes from.
Initially, we actually saw her visiting her family
there during the events of what if season
one, these soldiers on horseback
In the background
are Hela Odin's army, the Asgardians.
Just like the mural in Thor Ragnarok.
She's writing Venomous Wolf Wielding your near,
which is Thor's Hammer in present day.
This is before Odin
put the wordiness enchantment on it.
So when Hela was wielding it thousands of years ago,
anybody could pick it up and use it.
when the watcher says firstborn daughter
HeLa, there's an interesting theory
that they confirm later in this episode
that's been going on since Thor Ragnarok came out.
After she's banished to Earth, she reveals that
Odin has recently started dating a really crazy woman
that she hates called Frigga referring to her
like she's never met Frigga before or barely knows.
Or like, I can't stand this.
The new woman that is sort of going out with Also,
my dad has a new girlfriend, Frigga.
She's a dreadful woman.
Not really a fan of hers either. So.
Yeah, it's just those three.
confirming that Frigga is not Halo's mother.
There were so many questions about this
after Thor Ragnarok came out in Avengers Infinity War
because during Thor Ragnarok, Odin only referred to
as Thor and Loki's sister, his first born.
when we got to Avengers
Infinity War, though, Thor refers to hell
as his half sister,
meaning that they had different mothers.
Thor wasn't born until after Odin imprisoned HeLa.
So like Frigga wasn't pregnant with Thor
when this was happening,
But in the MCU movies,
they never explicitly stated who Heller's mother was.
If it was in Frigga in Norse
mythology is very different.
Like the backstory behind all the characters
and relationships are very different.
She's actually the daughter of Loki in a giantess.
She's born on Johan Heim.
Where Loki comes from in Odin
eventually makes her the ruler of hell.
Their underworld in the comics.
HeLa is not Thor's sister or even part of his family.
She's just another God who rules over hell.
AGL inside the MCU movies.
They made her a little bit
more like Angela from the comics.
Thor's secret sister.
during the episode, HeLa
never reveals who or actual mother was.
So like, the theories will continue after this.
Like, who is it?
Probably the best current theories right now
is that it was just another cosmic being
or another Asgardian Shield maiden who died
at some point
that Odin just had relations with
because Frigga is supposed to be his first actual wife.
Like he wasn't married to anyone before Frigga.
But that would also mean that HeLa was a bastard child
that he legitimized.
there's a whole backstory of Asgard, Odin, the MCU,
that's very different in a way more a Game of Thrones.
The in the comics,
it involves a huge power struggle within Odin's family
going back to the time of his grandfather.
this is Odin's grandfather, not Thor's grandfather.
I could do a whole video
just explaining the backstory of the Asgardians
just in general,
but it's not super relevant to this episode.
Needless to say, Odin slept around a lot.
A lot, as he did in Norse mythology.
So hell, his mother could be any one of the women
he got down with but was not married to.
the watcher continues to narrate this backstory
as they pan around the mural more You see the Valkyries
fighting the frost giants in the background
when they reference the branches of the world tree.
Loki literally just reorganized the multiverse
into a more cosmic version of the world tree
on a much grander scale than the world tree
representing the nine realms inside the MCU.
They basically continue with her version of the scene
from the first Thor movie.
She's in the middle of rebelling against Odin,
taking out all the guards inside the Bifrost.
I think her plan here was to forcibly
take the throne of Asgard from Odin.
They continue their war of conquest
across the universe.
they give her a reverse version of the scene
from Thor Ragnarok,
where she broke Thor's hammer after catching it
with Odin, catching it and breaking it this time.
R.I.P.
Mule near pretty much all of Odin's dialog here
is the exact same thing that he said to Thor during
that first Thor movie when he was taking his power
and putting the word this enchantment on his hammer.
Whosoever who has this crown, should she?
No mercy shall possess the power of Allah.
he takes her crown, does the same thing with her power.
This is all done through magic.
Like he uses magic to strip her of her power
and give her a helmet.
The worthiness enchantment.
when he says his father and his father before him,
they kind of briefly brush across this in the Thor
movies.
Odin's father was named Boar
and his grandfather was named Beri.
Asgard itself did not exist as a kingdom
when his grandfather was still alive
and king of their people Originally, Odin
and all of his people come from a race called the Asir.
well wound up happening is that Odin's father
bore became the next king after his grandfather.
But because brother actually left and created
the Kingdom of Anaheim rebelling against them.
so became this whole Game of Thrones thing
with their kingdoms fighting against each other.
And they formed a peace by marrying Bors son
Odin, to his brother's daughter, who was Frigga.
So Odin basically married his cousin
to seal the peace treaty.
marrying your cousin.
Also very Game of Thrones.
they just had they get down in the Marvel Universe.
Odin casts held to Earth.
She lands in China in the middle
of Wenwu army in the ten rings in the distant past.
remember, this is before Thor's been born.
So it's about 1500 years ago
when the watcher says the most powerful forces on Earth
often come from beyond, that's a reference to the ten
rings coming from another planet or another dimension,
which they still have not confirmed
where they actually came from.
In the MCU, the designs on the ten rings look similar
to Kang's designs in Asia and the WASP Quantumania.
But given the way things have gone down since then,
the way they treated the character during him
and the WASP quantumania,
I don't think they can created the ten rings.
They're still transmitting that signal
to who knows where
I think to another dimension,
and they'll pay that off in Sheng Shi two.
And they just confirmed
that they're actually working on that movie,
but no idea when we're actually going to see it.
I think that the source or the origin of the ten rings
will have something to do with Avengers
five and Avengers six.
So it's possible that they came from another universe
because we're talking about big multiverse
overarching plot right now.
I don't think any of the current theories
about where the ten rings came from are correct.
Like people trying to tie them to Galactus
or a nihilist, like other really big Marvel characters.
I think that Marvel is going to do something similar
to what they did in the first Shang-Chi movie,
where they create a bunch of new law in back story
for the ten rings that doesn't exist in the comics.
They use the standard.
What if intro. There's
no special new scenes during this.
And then when his winds up finding Heller and plays
like a stab your version of the plot
from the first Thor movie when he arrived on Earth,
they reveal Heller also knows how to speak Mandarin
when she is mocking him, talking about bowing
before her as their queen.
It's the same thing
she said to Thor during Thor Ragnarok.
then the scene of her trying to pick up her
helmet is just like Thor trying to lift his hammer.
In the first Thor movie.
they wind up taking her back to Wenwu's ten Rings
compound is meant to be the exact same place
that you saw in the Shanghai movie.
They take some chemistry
between them, Maybe eventually they do get together
at some point in the distant future.
It seems like he does
have some kind of attraction to her, but he's mostly
attracted right now
to her desire for battle in conquest.
She escapes and gets help by a creature
like Morris from the Shang she movie.
It's not.
Morris himself is just like another member
of his species who leads her to the enchanted forest
that protects the entrance to Tall low, the gateway
between dimensions.
when she mentions the first asked that
she followed in the battle that's meant to be Odin.
we get a quick shot of the watcher
peeping her from the sky as she rides past
they get a lot of quips during the episode
but she's very quippy Tony Stark style
but there are a couple of funny moments here with her
making fun of his butt face
because it just looks kind of like about, like,
am I talking to your butt or talking to your face?
What's the deal here? How does this work?
When she references the creature, telling her
she'll find what she seeks beyond this valley.
The whole idea is that it's helping her
find a place to hide from everyone.
Because Wenwu cannot enter tallow,
she's trying to find a place to escape from everyone
She confirms that she's over a thousand years old
because her battle to conquer the nine realms lasted
at least a thousand years.
So she had to be a little bit older than that.
They make it into tallow in that other dimension.
And she's attacked by Jai Ying, who's the current
protector of the barrier between dimensions.
It's the same role that Zheng,
she's mother served later in the timeline,
but this is meant to be a totally different character.
Like it isn't his mother who hell is fighting
Then the reason.
Heimdall can no longer see her in TALOS
because his ability only allows him to see most
not everything, but most things in the MCU
universe in Tableau is in another dimension.
she literally fell off the map
because she's in another universe.
She wakes in the village, in Tallow,
the Firebird she sees are from the Shanghai movie.
Everything here in the village
is meant to be the exact same.
This was just 1500 years ago. In the past.
So they've trapped the dweller in darkness.
Creature already in the mountain prison.
That's why the village was created in the first place
to house all the people living there for the purposes
of ensuring that it stayed in its prison,
when she says she wasn't aware of such magic
still existing on Midgar,
she's probably referring to the age of Merlin Camelot.
When I think sorcerers were more prevalent
across the map.
I think part of the idea is that over time,
more sorcerers started to congregate
around Kamar Taj and basically hide themselves
from public knowledge
with a few exceptions,
like Doctor Strange, for instance, who's super famous,
like everybody in the MCU,
like common people know who he is,
She says their village is here to protect the main 616
dimension from threats from the underworld.
That's also a reference to the dweller in Darkness.
And HeLa in
the comics is from the Asgardian underworld.
Hell, AGL she confirms Odin's started her relationship
with Frigga in Thor.
Hasn't been born yet.
Like I talked about this earlier, confirming
that Frigga is not her
mother Let me know in the comments
who you actually think that it is like.
I think it's probably just some random person
that he got down with at some point
before he actually became king.
she convinces them to teach her their special space
kung fu fighting abilities,
which are basically like kung
fu mixed with airbending to make more Avatar.
The Last Airbender references.
We just had the cohort episode in the MCU.
She's kind of like an energy bender, so lots of Avatar,
The Last Airbender energy going on inside the
What If series she sees the great protector dragon
and almost winds up crapping her pants.
Odin then declares war on.
Wenwu coming to take the ten rings, thinking
that he was responsible for Hela's death, mistakenly.
when she starts watching the man
practicing the abilities saying she'd rather do that
with fire or knives or fire knives,
they do pay that off.
Later in her fight with Odin, where she actually uses
the fire knives, Jiayi basically gives Hela
a PTSD flashback to her childhood with a young,
venomous wolf who seems like a typical pup.
She seems like a totally normal
asgardian child, super happy.
And I think the idea here is that Odin
basically beat the happiness out of her
and turned her into the killing machine.
She is in present day.
like he twisted her to be this way
when he was still a really bad
like if you thought he was a bad dad, the Thor,
he was way worse before Thor came along.
Which is why HeLa is the way that she is.
she comes to the realization
that the thing she really wants is in conquest
is actually true freedom
and then vows to free the entire universe,
starting with the nine realms, which basically amounts
to her getting rid of all the warlords, despot
or other God level beings
that are terrorizing the universe.
they give her a bigger training montage
as she masters their fighting techniques,
which is basically what we saw during the Shang
She movie,
like a version of the training montage that he got
when he was learning their fighting techniques.
then because this is like a super quick
speedrun type of episode, Odin arrives
immediately on earth to take the ten rings
hallow, leaves hollow, never to return.
They don't follow because they have to stay in guard.
The dweller in darkness is prison
like that's still going on in the background.
she joins wenwu.
They team up to fight Odin together
now with her space kung fu in airbending powers
their conflict basically comes down to him
refusing being too stubborn to see her desire
for freedom for the universe like
it has to be Odin's way like no, no, no, I am the king.
I said that it's going to be this way.
It has to be this way, The way the fight goes down,
obviously, Hela wins for plot reasons mostly.
In reality, Odin in the comics
is way more powerful than Odin in the MCU,
the Odin force makes him
one of the most powerful beings in the universe
next to like the Celestials
or other cosmic entities like the Phenix.
There are more powerful beings.
Like the Phenix is way more powerful than Odin,
obviously.
ba. Like the Odin force doesn't reside in his spear.
And in the episode they use that as a big MacGuffin.
Like get him away from his spear.
That'll deep down, big time.
In reality, that wouldn't do much of anything.
The spear is meant to be super powerful,
like stormbreaker or mutineer,
but is like Thor in the MCU, Odin's God level power
resides inside him, not inside the spear.
so just like Thor.
They don't actually need weapons.
They are the weapon.
but are they just for plot reasons in the episode?
They want this to mirror
the first Thor movie in the Zhang Xi movie.
So like, they want it to be an actual weapon
that they get away from him.
She's able to defeat him using her new abilities
in the scene of her becoming worthy
is also a copy of the first Thor movie, with him
becoming worthy, getting his hammer back,
He offers her the throne of Asgard, and it seems like
he's happy with the way things went down.
Like, you've evolved as a person. I'm so happy for you.
basically letting her do whatever she wants
as the new queen of Asgard,
they explain that basically amounts to her freeing
the nine realms, like reversing Odin's conquest
or the damage done by his conquest, then
doing the same thing around the rest of the universe.
But it takes thousands of years
for them to make it around the universe.
they show her with the new army, with Wenwu
still fighting with her because the ten rings slowed
his aging, allowing him to live for almost forever,
as long as he continued to wear them
They arrive on tomorrow's homeworld, just as Stannis
army is balancing it.
This seems basically taken directly from Avengers
Infinity
War implying that she stopped or killed Thanos
then went on to stop all the other warlords,
the gods who were conquering other worlds,
enslaving people, or just killing tons of people,
basically mopping up the universe one world at a time.
Kind of doing a reverse version of Thanos.
This quest to balance the universe, balancing it
but in another direction
perfectly balanced is all things should be.
like I said too, because they implied
that chemistry between her and Wenwu earlier,
even though she had no interest in getting married,
that doesn't mean that she was willing
to actually get down with him.
Eventually they can imply that
maybe they started a relationship at some point
that actually means in this universe
she would become showing she's mother instead.
meaning that showing
she would actually be her son in this universe.
it was a pretty solid episode,
even if it was a little too short.
Like I was hoping for just like a little bit more like
it was a super speed run version of all those movies
jammed together.
Cate Blanchett is an amazing actress.
No matter what kind of dialog they gave her,
she would have done an amazing job with it
there are a bunch of Easter eggs and references.
So if you spotted any that
I didn't talk about in the video, just write them below
in the comments in my full episode video
we'll post tomorrow.
That'll be the Marvel 1602 episode.
It looks like it is going to be a banger,
isn't a pay off all those post-credits scenes
we just saw with Scarlet Witch, Merlin Supreme Straight
pulling all those characters
from across the multiverse to their teams.
I do know Scarlet Witch's
team is on the opposite side of Supreme Strange's team
or if they're working together.
But I believe that Cate Blanchett
is also coming back again in that episode
is another version of Hell,
not hell of the white that we saw in episode seven.
I think the Marvel 16 to hell
is meant to be the Queen Scarlet
Witch referred to
when they said they were trying to save their queen.
And it's meant to be a version of Bella
who's more like Queen Elizabeth.
The first in is Meta Easter Egg,
because in real life, Cate Blanchett
also played a version of Queen Elizabeth,
the first in the movies.
The circle of Easter Eggs is now complete.
They did not reveal
who the main villain of that episode is going to be.
It sounds more like a Civil War situation
with a bunch of different Marvel characters
fighting on opposite sides of this war
that's going on in this universe.
but we will have an actual main villain
during the finale.
So whatever happens during that Marvel 1602 episode,
it sounds like whatever main villain
will wind up actually rising amongst all that stuff
and it'll just spill into the finale.
kind of the same way they did things during season
one with that Infinity Stone version of Ultron.
Like you see him during episode eight, then
in the finale, just things carry forward into that.
There's a bunch of other stuff coming up,
so I try to do videos for everything.
The next couple of days.
Be sure to enable alerts from my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
Click here for that Episode 8 video.
Update the link as soon as I post it, and click here
for all my What If episodes.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!